- But it's nice to meet you, Abigail.
- It's so nice to meet you.
It's so funny because I was,
I was remembering that when
I did Little Miss Sunshine,
I had to listen to headphones
in the scene and I was
actually listening to
music because Alan Arkin,
there's a scene where
there's some language that I,
- oh,
- cannot repeat on television,
but, and Alan was very-very,
like, not comfortable
having me listen to it.
So he would always check to make sure
that I had the headphones on,
and was actually listening to music.
So I was listening to the Breakaway album.
- Are you serious?
(audience cheering)
what?
- The whole time that
you're watching that,
- So..
- I'm listening to like 'You Found Me'.
- Oh my gosh, that's a deep cut, okay
Wait, so technically I was
in Little Miss Sunshine.
That's what I just heard.
- We have to change the DVD now.
- Technically, I'm a star
at Little Miss Sunshine.
That's all I heard.
- Yes, exactly.
- That's amazing. I love that
they did that for you though.
He was like, I'm uncomfortable
with cursing so much
in front of the child.
- Even at the premiere, he was like,
he was sitting next to
me and would be like,
to my mom he'd be like,
can you get her out of the theater please?
Like, for that scene.
- Oh my Gosh
- Yeah, Yeah
- That is sweet.